[Musica]
la scorsa settimana a cena in famiglia
parlavamo della presentazione che avrei
fatto questa sera e mia figlia in un
misto di sincerità come sempre e iranian
mi ha chiesto Ma perché hanno scelto
proprio te per parlare e con questa
iniezione di fiducia
parlo anch'io di futuro anche perché
quando si parla di futuro fiducia e
ottimismo sono sicuramente necessari
perché se pensiamo al nostro futuro al
futuro delle nostre organizzazioni
tendenzialmente lo pensiamo in un'ottica
di obiettivi quello che vogliamo
raggiungere come vogliamo raggiungerlo
magari con chi e anche In che tempi e il
macro obiettivo che tutte le
organizzazioni e le aziende si pongono
la nascondiamoci è quello di ottenere
una certa forma di successo questo è
l'obiettivo che tutte le aziende
giustamente si pongono definendolo in
modo diverso
ognuno con dei kpi e degli obiettivi
diversi Ma alla fin fine Una certa forma
di successo la definizione di successo
negli anni è cambiata ed è voluta credo
un evoluzione culturale molto virtuosa
si è passati da una definizione più
stretta di massimizzare il profitto
degli azionisti profitto valore nel
senso di valore economico Se passate una
definizione molto più ampia e più
virtuosa di massimizzare il valore in
senso lato per tutti gli stakeholder
coinvolti nel processo e nel percorso
Quindi se gli azionisti gli investitori
che meritano un ritorno
sull'investimento ma in realtà tra gli
stakeholder sono sicuramente importante
le persone che lavorano all'interno
dell'azienda fornitori clienti il
consumatore finale
per poi allargarsi alla comunità in cui
le aziende lavorano alle istituzioni con
cui interagiscono e per allargarsi
ulteriormente in modo sempre più
virtuoso per pensare al nostro pianeta e
l'ambiente che ci circonda e ad un
generale benessere delle persone
gli ingredienti per ottenere successo
sono tanti le ricette sono diverse
diffidare sempre di Chi presenta a
ricette modelli rigidi e pensa di poter
copiare e incollare il modello e la
ricetta da un'azienda all'altra perché
in realtà cambiano tutti gli ingredienti
sono meritevoli e tutti quanti i pro
enti possono essere utili per
determinare il successo di
un'organizzazione però se mi permettete
di rovinare il finale di questa storia
ce ne sono uno del quale non si può fare
a me e del fattore persone
negli ultimi anni abbiamo visto un
crescente interesse verso di excim e
all'interno di Virgili il fattore
persone è fondamentale non è un caso che
la s di esg sia quasi interamente
dedicato alle persone e al loro
benessere non è un caso perché
imprenditori azionisti Sio e Chiunque
abbia un ruolo di leadership si accorta
di essere circondato appunto Da quegli
stakeholder che oggi
pretendono che le aziende siano
sensibili ai valori sottostanti 10 ma si
sono anche accorte le stesse persone
imprenditori se io azionisti persone che
hanno un ruolo di leadership che esiste
una equazione fondamentalmente vera che
lega il successo delle imprese alle
persone
Se produciamo queste equazioni in
termini un po' più comuni all'interno
delle aziende le persone vengono spesso
definite Talenti e si sa che le aziende
che hanno talenti che performano portano
a casa risultati migliori
per evitare che questa rimanga una buona
slide in una rappresentazione di
Powerpoint
benedire che la letteratura è molto
Concorde su questo aspetto esistono
tantissime ricerche che validano questa
equazione recentemente
molto interessante fatta su 19.000
aziende hanno identificato un cluster di
azienda all'interno di queste 19.000 e
sono quelle che dedicano gran parte del
tempo allo sviluppo delle persone al
loro benessere e soprattutto alla loro
performance e queste aziende ottengono
risultati eclatanti
per esempio sono in grado di generare un
ritorno sui capitali investito per gli
azionisti di quasi cinque volte
superiore alle aziende del resto del
pane sono in grado di generare tassi di
crescita e massa critica 3,6 volte
superiore alle altre aziende del pane
e nei due anni successivi alla pandemia
hanno reagito alla crisi molto ma molto
meglio degli altri generando tasse di
crescita anche doppi rispetto alle altre
aziende del pane
questa equazione è un'equazione che ho
fatto mia nel tempo Io amo la matematica
da sempre e l'ho approfondita perché
credo che in realtà sia un'equazione che
è in grado di trasformare il capitale
umano quindi Talenti in vantaggio
competitivo quindi Seguitemi brevemente
in pochi minuti in questo percorso
matematico Forse meglio dire aritmetico
abbiamo detto persone uguale è successo
ossia il successo generato dalla
sommatoria delle performance individuali
di tutte le persone che compongono
l'organizzazione o che stanno attorno a
organizzazione
in questa equazione c'è una parola
fondamentale che è performance perché
l'individuo da solo ahimè non basta
bisogna che le aziende mettano i talenti
e gli individui nella posizione di poter
portare valore aggiunto di performare
quindi focalizzando l'attenzione su che
cosa è in grado di determinare la nostra
performance come Individui e la
performance delle persone che lavorano
attorno a noi Beh sono due i fattori
abbastanza semplici da un lato le
competenze per poter far bene Dobbiamo
saper fare una cosa le competenze
tecniche Quindi quello che sappiamo fare
quello che abbiamo imparato quello che
potenzialmente abbiamo studiato
all'Università o nei corsi di formazione
o magari che qualcuno ci ha insegnato
Queste sono fondamentali l'equazione non
funziona se ci se ci uguale a 0 P sarà
uguale a 0
se noi però pensiamo alla seconda
fattore fattore un po' più difficile da
gestire perché il fattore che ricopre le
mette insieme tutti i nostri softsky la
nostra
competenza indicano quello che sappiamo
fare
l'attitudine indica come facciamo queste
cose come le approcciamo e anche come
interagiamo con tutte le persone che ci
stanno attorno
scia
e tu un percorso matematico aritmetico
interagiscono tra di loro all'interno di
una formula che esalta la esalta la a
come amplificatore di performance
da un lato noi i ruoli dividersi
imprenditori Sio Chiunque abbia un ruolo
di leadership all'interno dell'azienda
deve lavorare per garantire la
performance delle proprie persone deve
lavorare su tutti e due gli elementi
sulla C con gli strumenti Giusti da un
lato con la giusta formazione con il
giusto trasferimento di conoscenza bene
o male dobbiamo imparare a fare una cosa
impariamo a farlo Non voglio sminuire
una c come ho detto C = 0 P uguale a 0 e
non voglio definirerla neanche perché le
stesse aziende virtuose della ricerca di
mckinsey di prima sono quelle che
investono maggiormente informazioni
investono circa 4 volte numero di ore
per persone all'anno informazioni
quindi non voglio non voglio dire
sminuirla però allo stesso tempo se la c
e nel complesso facile
la Pio è un bel casino
perché Perché fa parte del nostro DNA
perché in realtà rappresenta un po' chi
siamo in un certo senso la versione di
noi stessi che portiamo in azienda che
non è sempre la stessa cosa come
sappiamo la è influenzata da tantissimi
aspetti influenzata dall'esperienza che
abbiamo avuto da come siamo stati
cresciuti magari anche della cultura di
provenienza ed è influenzata tantissimo
dalle persone che abbiamo incontrato nel
nostro percorso da un capo o una capra
che ci hanno ispirato ci hanno
trasferito conoscenza che ci hanno dato
tanta motivazione rispetto a un capo una
cappa che ci hanno tappato le ali
non è un caso che chi ha pensato al
concetto delle quattro P del successo
l'abbia pensate tutte in ottica di
attitudine avere scopo avere passione
avere perseveranza avere positività sono
tutti aspetti che vanno ad aumentare ed
aiutare il nostro modo di fare le cose e
di approcciare le cose
come ho detto che ruoli di leadership
deve lavorare su tutti i due aspetti
deve lavorare sulle competenze
attraverso la formazione attraverso il
trasferimento di conoscenza ma deve
anche lavorare tanto subartito
come facciamo nel nostro ruolo a
lavorare sulla Attitude delle nostre
persone in modo da garantire una
maggiore e una migliore performance
Bisogna chiedere ai talenti che cosa
vogliono me e se noi chiamiamo i talenti
cosa vogliono ci dicono una marea di
cose ma fondamentalmente si riassumono
tutte in un unico grande concetto che il
concetto delle engagement Perché le
persone all'interno di un'organizzazione
vogliono sentirsi motivate coinvolte
parte di qualcosa di più grande
Allora proviamo a chiedere ad un talento
Vi presento Elena e lentamente
discutibile Beh se ne chiedessimo Elena
che cosa può aiutare a Motivare a creare
engagement e a lavorare sulla sua
Attitude all'interno dell'azienda
facciamo Selene analista la prima cosa
che cita forse l'aspetto economico e lo
togliamo subito dal campo sarebbe Naif
nel non mettere sul piatto anche questo
aspetto perché le aziende che sono in
grado di attrarre di trattenere Talenti
sono le aziende che sanno anche pagare
in modo adeguato i propri Talenti
in realtà la cosa che i talenti
maggiormente chiedono e conoscenza
conoscenza che permetta loro di crescere
professionalmente e di crescere anche
personalmente
si parla tanto ultimamente di scheda
alternativi e se ne parla tanto perché
Perché le carriere si stanno allungando
tantissimo un dato se vogliamo in un
certo senso anche inquietante dice che
il 50% dei bambini di 5 anni di oggi mi
verranno fino a cent'anni che vuol dire
che le carriere che oggi sono già molto
Rubber di 40 e 45 anni domani
supereranno i 50 e alcuni esperti dicono
che arriveranno addirittura a 60 anni
pensare di trattenere un talento in un
binario di carriera unico per così tanto
tempo è impensabile
offrire loro skill alternativi per poter
cambiare corsia eventualmente percorso
sarà un vantaggio competitivo per tante
aziende
il trasferimento di conoscenza spesso
avviene nelle aziende da capo a riporto
diretto da collega avere quindi persone
che ispirino all'interno dell'azienda
che facciano Questo trasferimento di
conoscenza che abbia una grande capacità
di ascolto un'altra delle grandi
richieste e Talenti oggi fa
questo non si poteva Non citare negli
anni POS pandemici abbiamo visto come la
necessità di benessere di equilibrio
vita lavoro sia crescente sicuramente un
altro elemento che sta stanno cercando
le persone ma retta ai Talenti vogliono
ambienti collaborativi dove ci sia una
buona comunicazione e per sfatare un
mito vogliono sfide Non è vero che i
ragazzi oggi abbiano meno voglia di
lavorare e non è vero che vogliono tutto
subito Forse magari un fondo di verità
c'è ma vogliono tante sfide perché sanno
che la sfida il Challenge uno strumento
fondamentale per quella crescita
professionale e personale che tanto
desiderano
e infine Cerca aziende etiche
trasparenti
che hanno grandi chiarezza di visione e
che condividono questa visione con tutte
le persone perché il talento vuole
capire qual è il suo ruolo all'interno
di uno scopo un po' più grande che
l'azienda si posa
se mettiamo tutti questi ingredienti
insieme siamo in grado di creare un
ambiente di lavoro positivo
stimolante sano che il punto di partenza
di un circolo virtuoso che può creare
migliore performance migliori risultati
per l'azienda e questo è quello su cui
chiaroni di leadership all'interno
dell'azienda deve assolutamente
focalizzare l'attenzione sul quale devi
focalizzare l'attenzione perché il
benessere la felicità delle persone
all'interno dell'azienda ha un valore un
valore che Harvard ha provato anche a
calcolare qualche anno fa in una ricerca
molto interessante ha isolato aziende
che sono particolarmente focalizzate
nell'ascoltare e nel provare a
soddisfare i bisogni dei propri
dipendenti e anche in questo caso come
prima i risultati sono stati eclatanti
se su alcuni aspetti un po' ce
l'aspettiamo se a una persona felice
all'interno dell'azienda è in grado di
focalizzare l'attenzione maggiormente di
generare diciamo Maggiore creatività
piuttosto che è più facile trattenere
una persona felice nella persona non
felice in azienda un po' ce lo
aspettavamo credo che meno Ovi siano i
risultati su una serie di altri
parametri per esempio su tutta una serie
di grandissime criticità che tutte le
aziende ogni tanto incontrano dalla
riduzione degli infortuni sul lavoro
alla riduzione dei problemati di qualità
sui prodotti o alla riduzione anche
della sentenza e infine impatto
notevolmente positivo anche su dei
parametri Direttamente collegati al
conto economico
questa equazione in pochi minuti è un
po' evoluta è diventata forse più una
una funzione una funzione che genera un
circolo virtuoso come dicevo prima che
ha un punto di partenza e il punto di
partenza e la focalizzazione sul Creare
un ambiente di lavoro sano positivo e
stimolante perché l'ambiente di lavoro
sano positivo e stimolante è in grado di
generare engagement motivazione e
coinvolgimento l'engagement è quello che
genera una migliore Attitude un
approccio positivo da parte delle nostre
persone la Attitude è un amplificatore
di performance e la performance è quello
che serve per portare a casa risultati
concreti il cerchio si chiude si chiude
Perché Perché Chiunque abbia vissuto
un'esperienza in aziende in forte
crescita che comunicano e fanno vedere
risultati positivi tutto quello Geneva
un grandissimo entusiasmo l'entusiasmo
che genera un ambiente ancora più
positivo e stimolante e che genera a sua
volta engage
stiamo vivendo in un periodo notevole di
evoluzione tecnologica
che da un lato entusiasmante da un lato
può anche essere che spaventi qualcuno e
la tecnologia sarà sicuramente una dei
fattori fondamentali per il successo
delle imprese del domani giustamente le
aziende investono tanto in quel però
credo che si sia capito che a mio avviso
la tecnologia sulla quale vale la pena
investire maggiormente in futuro
Rimaniamo sempre noi le nostre persone
con le nostre competenze la nostra
Attitude e i nostri valori Grazie